it's been four months since a massive
explosion at beirut's port destroyed and
damaged surrounding neighborhoods
killing 200 people and injuring
thousands
an investigation has yet to provide an
explanation
on what caused nearly 3 000 tons of
ammonium nitrate
to explode
[Music]
but for the first time senior officials
are being charged
the caretaker prime minister hassan dieb
along with three former ministers
are accused of negligence deep says
his conscience is clear and that he has
no intention of being questioned again
he is now the first prime minister in
lebanon's history to be charged
dieb was forced to resign days after the
blast but later returned as caretaker
he was only in power for a few months
when the explosion happened
that's why some are questioning the
judicial decision
the deep state is protecting itself and
the clearest indicator to that
is with that accusation to the current
prime minister they also accused
three previous transportation ministers
who are directly responsible for the
port
but failed to accuse the three previous
prime ministers
who've been in power since 2014 when the
nitrate
ammonium shipments came into lebanon so
it is very clear that this has been a
very selective accusation
by the deep state which includes the
major six political parties and their
leaders
deb repeatedly acknowledged receiving
prior warnings about the dangers posed
by the ammonium nitrate
but he wasn't the only one so far low
and mid-level employees at the port and
custom authorities have been charged
and that is why there has been so much
public anger
official correspondence between various
branches of government
show the president the now caretaker
prime minister
former and current ministers as well as
security officials and judges
knew that large amounts of explosive
material were at the
port and failed to take action
it was one of the world's biggest
non-nuclear explosions and for many
it was the direct result of corruption
encouraged by a political class that
governed
for decades
this is not enough all this destruction
in beirut is due to a history of
corruption
before hassan jab and after him they
should question all of them
families of the victims have been
protesting against the delay in justice
now a high-ranking official is being
held to account but this process could
drag
on for years already some are saying
dieb is being unfairly targeted
he once said corruption is bigger than
the state
senator al-jazeera beirut